hi guys I am just McDonald I am Zuri T
and you're joining us for another
episode of house of cards today we are
playing Sarina a game from sin scape the
name you might recognize from the
Kickstarter for asylum
okay I'm gonna warn you now guys we're
gonna go on a narrative adventure cuz
there's a lot of talking he's talking
about this girl named Serena one can
assume it's his wife or girlfriend but
we're learning this cabin in the world
that was rude I don't know why they did
with the little girl in the middle yeah
I mean I think we were meant to find
each other okay so he's having trouble
remembering things
she's so yeah look at his vast array of
room shall i wear the light green or the
off-white i don't know if he killed her
I feel like you might have killed her
it's a boy oh my god oh she's got a face
well she uh she's not what I expected
she's got a unique beauty that should be
the house for Horrors
oh my god that should be oh oh she's
angry
yes she does actually whoa okay that's
interesting it's finally it's done and
get oh he's starting even specs things
again and he says them more negatively
I've been trying so hard but we lost
something along the way
Oh Jase also scary insulin fresh
let's just look at the porn and calm
down okay he's not even interested in
porn anymore I can't fix this guy so you
know he's stunned to see the negative oh
my god II opened it do you realize all
the pain you've caused me they say if
you have to ask whether someone loves
you you already know the answer what's
mom she's pretty [ __ ] my real color
faded from long ago
just like your relationship people just
get so angry and I think it's because
people are so vulnerable they get so
angry angry I think the bodies in the
closet I'm gonna go look in a second oh
oh oh my god um it's a person need a
killer oh my god it's already rotting
beyond recognition
well [ __ ] what the cook stopped oh
that's creepy is this am i dead Oh
do you realize how stupid is that
[ __ ] okay so they killed him and they
bent it down for the evidence oh you can
get that for free now on Steam if you
wish guess who's back back again lúcia
back we're back with its lucious
house-made Javita will be our next
victim if you missed volusia stream last
time yes it's probably worth checking
out I feel like was fun this game is
quite fun yeah oh you're a genius
Oh Oh super great super great super
grace oh it was okay I see peeping tom
peeping tom holy [ __ ] I'm sure we can do
something through that hole you know I
wish I hadn't said that oh did I just
look myself and we should have picked up
the keys we didn't probably drop the
keys over to us with them telekinesis
keys
okay so close oh you to drag my god well
it's a satanic child problems my resolve
I just said son of Satan trapped self in
storage cage dad these are all the rooms
of dead people it's a bike we're gonna
bike
let's just be a complete dick I love
that there's no animation to him to get
oh oh
hit him with a phone Oh what's all this
Oh a shoe oh oh my god sex no wait wait
it says when you find the uncle don't go
in the room oh my god everyone's saying
home scare the back end if you hashtag
home scared
make it happen Oh yep look artistic
sculptures Raj Kim said take your time
uncle has loads of stamina Oh
I love a bit of fills in the afternoon
children this is a closed door that's
[ __ ] behind it 28 says so she's
supposed to recognize his but he surely
didn't capture his face that button nice
now you oh my god this gave you bad guys
so as the son of Satan I have
mind-control powers as well but they
need to be in a weak state they're all
dead oh yeah we keep killing them the
kid is just a jerk he's not possessed
he's just a jack oh holy crap demonic
much yeah he's so evil he's in on it
oh-oh-oh
with this bottle why are you - oh okay
so that was malicious and the best game
we played there's a free-to-play game
you can get cool sarena they'll both be
in the highlights where I'll say if you
want to take a look at algorithm I'll
see the first half of when we play
Lucius you can do that with either the
full stream which is on Twitch from last
week on the highlights reel which is on
game YouTube um but as usual leave us
your comments and your thoughts on our
HOH life Twitter hashtag that's right we
are checking all the tweets um let us
know if you want us to play a particular
game next week and we do read all the
comments too thank you and we'll
hopefully see you again next week thanks
guys bye
you